Now, we don't expect our predictions to be 100% accurate. There will almost
always be some error in our predictions. And that's in terms of the residuals.
How can we quantify how much error we have? Well, remember mean and standard
deviation when we just had one variable? We had distributions that were fat and
skinny. And our expected value was always the mean. But we could always pick a
random value that's out here in the tails, and that's due to error. And how did
we measure this error? We used standard deviation as a measure to tell us how
far we expect most scores to fall from the mean. Now, let's take a step back.
We have two data sets. We'll just call them red and blue for now. They have the
same regression line, as shown by this black line. You're trying to estimate
the y value when x equals 12. The expected or predicted value will be the same
for both, since they have the same regression line. But we can bet that the
actual or observed value won't be exactly equal to this. It might be somewhere
up here or down here, we won't know. We can only guess. But, for which data
set, red or blue, do you expect the actual measurement will be closer to the
prediction.